Aujourd'hui, je ne veux rien expliquer.
Je veux juste dire merci !
Merci à l'ensemble du personnel soignant des hôpitaux qui depuis plusieurs semaines
lutte contre le coronavirus et sauve des vies.
Les médecins, les infirmiers, les aides-soignants masculins et féminins,
le personnel administratif,
les pompiers, les ambulanciers,
les pharmaciens également, le personnel des établissements d'accueil, les forces de l'ordre.
Mais comme aujourd'hui,
c'est la journée du travail invisible
et que nous sommes tous confinés,
je voulais aussi saluer le travail de celles et ceux
que nous ne voyons plus
ou auxquels nous ne pensons pas :
les boulangers, les minotiers
qui continuent à moudre du blé
pour que nous ayons de la farine et du pain.
les éleveurs qui continuent
à s'occuper de leurs animaux,
à traire leurs vaches, leurs brebis et leurs chèvres.
Qui pour certains continuent à faire du fromage.
Le personnel des laiteries qui continue
à ramasser le lait à le transformer.
Merci à nos bouchers, nos charcutiers, nos fromagers
et nos poissonniers.
Merci à nos producteurs de céréales,
de fruits et de légumes
qui travaillent dans leurs champs,
qui taillent et qui récoltent,
qui plantent et qui sèment pour que d'ici quelques semaines, quelques mois
nous ayons dans nos assiettes et dans nos verres
de bons produits.
Merci à tous ceux qui les conditionnent
et les acheminent vers nos magasins,
à ceux qui les mettent en place,
les caissiers, les caissières,
le personnel d'entretien, de maintenance,
de traitement des déchets.
Merci à tous ceux qui nous permettent d'avoir
de l'électricité et du gaz.
Derrière chaque produit que nous consommons,
chaque service que nous utilisons,
il y a une filière avec des femmes et des hommes
qui réalisent des tâches que nous ne connaissons pas.
Merci aux journalistes qui continuent à nous informer,
aux enseignants qui continuent à travailler à distance,
aux météorologues qui regardent le ciel,
aux volcanologues qui surveillent les volcans,
aux biologistes qui ont l’œil rivé sur le coronavirus,
aux chercheurs qui continuent à chercher
parce que plus que jamais,
on ne sait pas ce que nous réserve l'avenir.
Merci à tous ceux qui font que
même en plein confinement,
la vie continue presque comme avant.
Et pardon à tous ceux que je n'ai pas cité.
Allez à demain et surtout n'oubliez pas :
nous sommes confinés mais on reste en lien.
Si vous avez aimé cette vidéo,
n'hésitez pas à laisser un pouce bleu.
J'en réalise une nouvelle chaque jour
alors pour ne rater aucune
de ces "capsules de déconfiné",
abonnez-vous et activez la petite cloche.
Merci à toutes et à tous et à demain !